what time is it ask that question to
someone on the street and you'll
probably get a nice straightforward
answer but ask that same thing to a
physicist and you're posing one of the
most deeply mysterious and uncertain
questions that science has to offer
because apparently the more you know
about what time actually is the harder
it is to answer that question what time
is it so just come out to six it's done
science fun science for example yeah
have you ever wondered whether or not
different animals experience time is
passing at different speeds say if time
is running slower from the point of view
of a hummingbird or running faster from
the perspective of a tor toys well we
actually have no idea about any of that
but what we do know is that the clock
inside the human brain our biological
clock can cause us to see if time is
passing a different rate fail me and
everything in your life revolves around
tea and you're about to take a sip when
suddenly the mug slips out of your hand
so that moment it feels like time slows
down now time isn't really slowing down
but because the dropping of the tea is
such a shock to your system they're
taking in as much as you can and it's
this overload of information that can
make us recall an incident as having
happened in slow motion however when it
comes to time well sometimes you only
perceive it as passing at different
rates
other times the speed of time literally
change it according to Einstein time is
a dimension but unlike the three
dimensions of space which were free to
move around in at will when it comes to
time we're stuck it not stationary or
else time wouldn't pass at all but we're
actually forced to travel three times at
the speed of light I know it's a
difficult concept to get your head
around but right now you sitting there
watching this video are traveling
through time at the speed of light
[Music]
something like that anyway this
intertwining of the three dimensions of
space and the fourth dimension of time
collectively called space-time does come
with a bit of push and pull though if
you're standing still you're traveling
through time at the speed of light but
if you are able to travel through space
that is near to the speed of light as
you could get then time would actually
slow down now from your perspective time
would still seem to be ticking at a
constant rate but if someone else were
able to gaze in on you as you travel
then you'd appear to be moving super
slowly gravity actually has a similar
effect on time too the more gravity
there is the more it bends and warp
space-time and the slower time ticks and
since gravity has a stronger pull the
closer you are to earth time actually
travels slower at your feet that it does
at your head now here on earth this time
difference was pretty much imperceptible
but take a black hole and objects with
an immense gravitational force so strong
that even light can't escape from it if
I fell into a black hole then from my
point of view I'd have a pretty awful
time first I'd be torn to shreds but
let's just imagine that wouldn't happen
from an outsider's perspective looking
in I fall in slower and slower and
slower until I appeared to stop
completely before I go the last thing I
want to show you is this photo called
the Hubble extreme deep field now
because it takes time for light to
travel everything that we see around us
technically exists in the past day today
here on earth this difference is pretty
negligible so consider the light from
the Sun now because our Sun is about 93
million miles away from us it might
takes about eight minutes to reach Earth
so if the Sun were to explode right now
we wouldn't actually be able to see it
for another eight minute if you look
even further away player on nearest
galaxy Andromeda you'll find its light
takes a whopping 2.5 million years to
reach us so when we look at the Hubble
extreme deep field picture which shows
only a tiny fraction of the galaxies in
our universe
but those galaxies nearest to us we're
seeing them as they existed millions of
years ago and a further galaxies are as
they looked billions of years in past
just by looking at this photo
you're literally able to see packs
through the history of the universe at a
glance and that is about all we have
time for hope you learn something bye
bye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which made you like cool thank you so
much for watching everyone also thanks
to my friends Lex and Sam for appearing
in this video please do subscribe to
them and thank you for watching this
mini fun science series if you missed
any of the episodes I'll put a little
playlist over there so you can check
them out and also a big thank you to
everybody who bought the coffee at love
my son Facebook I have put a lot of work
into this and I just really appreciate
seeing people like find a new enthusiasm
for science that's kind of what this is
all about about kind of creating new
science fans so I really hope I've been
able to do that for you and yes my copy
of the book if you want to put no
pressure
I'm just happy with it happy with this
happy generally happy charlie vessel bye
bye